From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Tuesday, March 11, 2013. My name is John Dittmer and I'm here in Jackson, Mississippi, with videographer John Bishop.
To interview Mr. Euvester Simpson, a leading activist in the Civil Rights Movement in Mississippi.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, D.C.
Miss Simpson, we are delighted to be here today and we thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
Let's begin by talking about your early life. Where were you born and raised?
I was born in the Mississippi Delta in Itta Bena, Mississippi and I lived there until I was about 14 years old on the youngest of seven children.
And during part of my parents' early marriage, my father was a butcher by trade.
But as times changed, part of their lives were spent as sharecroppers.
And when they had times that were good, they would leave the plantation and move to Greenwood, Mississippi.
And once they moved to Greenwood and several of my siblings were born when they actually lived in Greenwood.
My mother was originally from the Mound Bayou. She was born and lived and grew up until she was 18 on her grandfather's farm.
My great grandfather actually attended college.
And I think he must have been in that first generation after emancipation.
So he actually went to college. He was a teacher and he was a minister. he pastored a church and he owned a farm.
And my mother was born and she grew up there until she met my father.
And it's really funny. I have to tell this story if we have a minute to let me digress.
My mother once told me how she met my father. It was during revival at my great grandfather's church.
And my great grandfather owned a car. He actually bought a brand new car.
I think it was a Model T.
And it was the kind that she had to go at when you started it, you had to go crank it up.
So she had met my father during the course of the revival.
And within a few days he had convinced her to elope with him.
And she said, well, she was really not sure about it.
So she asked God to give her a sign if she wasn't supposed to do that.
So they went out and she had put on two of everything, two dresses, just doubled up because she knew she was ill-open.
And she went out and got in the car.
And my great grandfather, she called in Buddy.
And she said Buddy went out to start the car.
And he was cranking and cranking and it wouldn't start.
And she said, a brand new car. She said, that was my sign and I knew it.
But I ignored it anyway. I ignored that sign.
And so the next night the car started and elope with him.
And when my parents got married, they moved to a farm that was owned by a friend of my great grandfather's.
And that's where they set up their life at first.
And while they were living on that, this particular man owned a lot of acreage.
And he had many tenants on his land.
And so my parents rented land from him and they formed.
And life was good until later on when things changed.
And this man lost his land and my great grandfather lost his land somehow.
And then they had to do sharecropping and other things in order to make a living for a while.
And when I was maybe 10 or 11, they finally left the plantation and we moved.
We actually moved to Itta Bena, Mississippi.
And during those years, my oldest sister, I mean my only sister got married when I was nine years old.
And she moved to Chicago and I would spend summers with her.
And eventually, now I'm going to talk a little bit about how the school year, the school system was set up when I was growing up.
Yeah, please do.
And I'm not sure what year.
I attended elementary school at Ellis Rogers.
That was on the campus of Mississippi Valley State University.
And by the time, and then I, during the seventh grade, seventh through the ninth grade, I attended school.
That was in Itta Bena, Mississippi right across the street from where we lived.
And when I got to the tenth grade, the school system had, the school board had consolidated the entire school system.
And they built a brand new school where all the black kids had to be bust in from across the county.
And the name of that school was Amanda Elzy High School.
And the problem with that is that, you know, some of the kids, I mean, we, it took us about maybe 45 minutes to get to school to an hour.
But some of the kids lived in, you know, the far end of the counties and it took a long time for them to get there.
And so at that point, we had what they call a split session, where we would go to school in the middle of the summer so the kids could be out to pick cotton.
Or no, not chop, but pick cotton during the fall.
And so I was the last child that my parents were raising and they were just kind of fed up with, you know, with the way the educational system was working.
And so she talked to my older sister and they decided that I would move to Racine when I was 14.
So I moved to Racine to go to high school.
I would, yeah, that is, we, I want to spend some time on that with a contrast.
That was very interesting, weren't you, were saying, but you grew up in the Mississippi Delta with somebody called the most southern place on earth.
Tell us a little bit about what it was like to be in the Delta.
Let me have a sip of water.
My parents were like most of the people, most of the other people in my community, they were, you know, economically depressed.
It was totally segregated. All the schools were segregated. The neighborhoods were segregated.
Most of the people made their living by either sharecropping or hiring themselves out as day workers to go and chop and pick cotton.
And so there were the teachers and the preachers and some shop owners because everything was totally segregated.
You know, we, it was like a sufficient community. We had, you know, dry cleaners and of course there were lots of churches and beauty parlors and maybe a convenience store.
Or two because my pay at my father later in life, this is after, I must have been 17 or 18 or he opened a convenience store.
And he ran that little store. It was actually built right next to the house that they owned.
But in the earlier years, it was a very close knit community where everybody looked out for everybody else.
And one of the things, but of course nobody was, I mean, everybody knew their place.
I mean, they knew. But most of these people had at some point been independent.
And either them or their, their parents had owned land until probably somewhere around the 20s or the 30s.
Most people lost their land and that's when they became sharecroppers. And totally dependent on, you know, the white people who had the economic power and everything else.
And so their lives, they felt like they had no power except to do as they were, as they were told to do.
And this really confined economically depressed area.
So, what was, how did you spend your days when you were a kid? Did you, did you work in the fields? Did you?
Oh, I did a little bit, but I mean, I was really young. I tried to chop cotton.
Wasn't very good at cutting it all down and I wasn't allowed to do it anymore, which was fine with me because I'm not an outdoor.
Doorsy person, I can't stand bugs. It, I mean, being a country girl from the Delta, you would think I'd have no problems.
But I'm scared to death of all kinds of bugs and spiders and things.
And I was never, I tried to pick cotton. I think maybe once or twice I may have picked about 50 pounds and, you know, that was not going to cut it.
When there were people picking maybe three and four hundred pounds a cotton a day.
But you have to remember I was only, you know, I was a kid.
What did you do to have fun?
Oh, I played with my friends, mud cakes, cooking and pretending to be, you know, cooking.
And we didn't have very many toys. We only received toys at Christmas, you know. I got, I got one toy at Christmas and then lots and lots of food and fruits and nuts and things.
Now one thing, okay, I mentioned earlier that my father was a butcher by trade. So what that meant was that in the fall,
and now my brother just reminded me of this recently because I don't have a great memory of this.
But in the fall, all the neighbors would get my father to come around to their house and kill a hog or something.
And so if he was not paid, I don't think he was paid in money. He was probably paid in cuts of meat.
Because I remember once when we were living on a plantation, we actually had a smokehouse.
And once, I mean, we were not allowed in it. But there were, you know, I went in it and it just about scared me to death.
I saw all these great big hams hanging up and my mother made homemade sausages and so it was just packed full of that kind of stuff.
And when I was growing up, they also had huge gardens and with all kinds of fresh vegetables and in the fall, my mother would can or make, you know, dry peas and beans.
But there was all kinds of fruits and vegetables. Did your siblings end up in pitch-in with all the work on that?
Oh, yes, yes, everybody did. And I guess because I was the youngest, I mean, I didn't, I didn't have to do very much.
And my sister absolutely hated it. So, and all of them did not like farm, none of them like farm work.
And I have a brother who lives in Detroit now and he is, he's 81 years old.
So there was, you know, there was, my mother had like five kids and then there was a gap and then she had two more at the end.
And so I'm that last one that she had.
But I was had a conversation with my brother. He came down here last year and he had before. He's still driving. He gets in his car and he drives down here and he gets around like he's 60.
So he was telling me that when he was like, okay, I have seven, there's seven of us and all.
I grew up with four with three other siblings or myself. So by the time I was three years old, my three older siblings were gone.
I just couldn't take any more. They left. And my brother, Sylvester, who lives in Detroit was telling me that when they first left home,
that they actually went to live with my grandparents for a while and they, my grandparents lived right outside of, it had been on a little community called Berclair, Mississippi.
And that's, and he told me that him and my older brothers, my other two brothers actually worked for the city of Greenwood. They, and they worked for the power company and I had no knowledge of this.
They worked for the city of Greenwood. I think picking up garbage and actually driving the garbage truck.
So, and my family too is a part of, you know, the great migration. They went as soon as they were old enough. They all left and they went north and they worked in the auto industry.
And, you know, they would send boxes of clothes back and they'd expect, you know, because they all had good jobs and they bought property and they were going.
What were your aspirations? What did you want to do when you grew up?
Well, when I thought that I would become an actor, that's what I had a passion for.
Did you go to the movies a lot?
No, not really. Well, yeah, well, sometimes I went to the movies. But when I was in like the third grade, I, you know, I had the leading roles in the plays. Well, I was in the seventh grade.
So, I got picked to have the leading role in the senior production. And now, what happened though? I probably would have had more experience as an actor as acting.
But when I left at 14 and I went to racing, it was a cultural shock. I went to a school that out of 2,000 kids there were maybe, like 10% of them were black, okay?
And, and so I joined the, the drama, the Dramatic Club and I never get picked. I picked four parts, you know, they were doing antigony and things like that.
And so I remember that the only part that I ever got was when we did Winnie the Pooh. I played the rabbit and Winnie the Pooh. Of course you were at all this makeup.
Yeah, yeah.
Everybody could tell what you are. Or anything. So that was a big disappointment. And so it was just a cultural shock for me to be.
And so, the teachers were white, even the janitors, the cooks in the, in the cafeteria.
By the time you got there, you had seen things that none of your classmates have in the orphan scene. And I was just doing some statistical checking.
And the lynching of Emmett Till occurred when you were what, about 10 years old.
I was 10, I think I was been, let's see, that was 54. I was 9 years old.
And let me, oh, I can tell you about that. I remember we used to get the jet magazine.
And we, of course, we had heard about Emmett Till. I was the first one to get the magazine.
And I started flipping through it and I got to this page where this picture of him was, you know, oh, I just remember screaming and throwing it across the room.
And I never wanted to see it again. You know, it was just absolutely horrible. Just horrible.
This was the bloated corpse that, yes.
May, me tell, Emma's mother insisted that the coffin be open. And thousands of people filed by in Chicago and it became one of the most famous photographs.
What, what was, what were your folks, you know, what, what kind of things do you remember what they were saying at the time? Did they give you, you know, it seems like every kid seemed like that they would think that could I be next?
Oh, we were all scared because we didn't know what was going to happen. You know, if they could kill, you know, a teenager for, you know, for something that, I mean, as minor as maybe looking at a white woman or trying to talk to her, we just didn't know what would happen.
And it was not long after that. It was either the year after I think the Reverend George Lee.
Yeah, talk about that. He was a friend of your father. He was a friend of my father's. Yeah. And my father was a member of the NAACP, but it was, it was just, you know, it's kept very quiet.
Yeah. My father went to the funeral and a couple weeks or so after that, we, they, a newsletter was sent out. Maybe a month back that a newsletter of his, you know, with pictures of the funeral and all the proceedings and all.
It was, was, was mailed out and we were still living on a, on a plantation at that point because I was, yeah, nine years old, nine or 10.
And we were looking through that newsletter, trying to find, see if my father was in some of the pictures.
And we could not find a picture of him. And so we just put it aside. And then later, what have us picked it up? And there he was on the front cover of that.
And just looking down at the casket and somehow we lost that. That newsletter.
For the sake of the audience, the Reverend George Lee was very active in voting rights at that time and was gunned down. And of course, nobody was ever tried or convicted of his crime.
The Brown decision saying that segregated schools were illegal, came out the year before and 54. Do you have any recollection of that and what it had no immediate impact in your area?
No, it had no immediate impact. I mean, things went on as they had always been we were still in segregated schools. I think maybe it did have some impact that we just, but not indirectly it was.
And there was some impact because that's right after that is when they built maybe right, you know, right at that, the school, the brand new elementary school that I attended starting in the third grade before then when the first school I went to was in a church.
And, you know, where they had two teachers, one for the little kids and one for the older students.
Yeah, that was the time that Mississippi legislature appropriated money to make separate but equal a fact thinking they could avoid desegregation. So a lot of schools got built.
Not too many laboratories, no libraries with books, but new buildings were built.
Want to go to Wisconsin shortly, but tell me about the spiritual life was a church an important part of your family's life.
The church was very important. I mean, you know, they were like I said earlier, my parents were like everybody else. They were hard working church going people. You went to church every Sunday and then Sunday afternoon. You were back there for the BTU and whatever else.
And then, you know, Bible on Wednesday Bible study on Wednesday. I mean, the church was really important. But when early on when my parents lived in the country, they didn't have church in there, you know, the church that they were members of every Sunday because the minister lived somewhere else.
And so he would come every other Sunday to church, but the church was very important and I was it was a center of everything, you know, every social activity, just everything.
And that was the only place where people could feel like that they could express themselves and have and demonstrate their leadership abilities or whatever.
My father was was a Sunday school teacher. And I remember, you know, once we were living in Itta Bena, he became like one of the major Sunday school teachers.
And my mother would spend Saturdays because he loved to have his things all demonstrated. She would use and butcher block paper writing out and drawing his fun to school lessons. So he could demonstrate it on on Sunday. So yes, the church was was extremely important.
You said that they decided to send you to Wisconsin with your sister because they were just sort of getting that up with the school system and the divided.
This must have been a tough decision though to send your little girl your last away.
Well, it wasn't all that tough because like I said, I had spent, you know, I'd gone away this couple summers to live with my sister.
And they were coming back every summer to visit, you know. So I was a fairly easy decision for them.
I was the youngest one and they, you know, they were getting older and they wanted to want me to have a, you know, a good solid education. But it was always a temporary thing. I had always intended to come back and go to college.
Tell us that you were mentioning that Racine was much different. It was very different.
I was, it was, I would end for a culture shock when I, especially the school, you know, like I said.
Yeah. So Racine then was different than the Mississippi Delta. Talk about your experiences there, school, town, how it was to make that adjustment.
Well, the major difference is that for the first time in my life, I actually, you know, interacted with white people.
I went to school with them because back in Mississippi, all the schools were totally segregated. But I actually, this was the first time.
And I actually had a few friends who were white at Washington Park High School. And the thing that was different about the school is that it was, I was just shocked that the, at all the, you know, the beautiful library, the equipment that they had.
And, and, you know, I was very athletic. So I, you know, I could, I played field hockey and soccer and, and I took tennis lessons and all that stuff.
And I was just, I did Tumblr and all of that stuff. And I'd never, I'd never been exposed to things like that. I just didn't even know that that kind of stuff existed, especially for high school.
But the main shock was that if, you know, you're lucky if you had one other black kid and you're in a class with you.
And, but I got along very well. I mean, after a while, but I was really embarrassed to tell people that I was from Mississippi. I got teased about that, you know.
Well, I really didn't have an accent problem. It's just was just being from, from Mississippi, you know, and people call it, oh, Bigfoot country and all that.
So I just didn't help very many people that I was from Mississippi because I was just, I didn't want to be teased about it, you know.
But my, my sister was on her, had gotten onto her second marriage and so her husband at that point when I went to live with her, had a daughter who's about my age and she was my protector.
We went to school together and she knew everybody, you know, because she had lived there all of her life, well most of her life.
And so she was very helpful to me. Her name was Ruth, Ruth Days. And we became best friends.
Did you run into any segregation problems there? Or was it a unique experience to go into a restaurant and sit down and to counter and have a coke?
You know, and I don't think things were segregated in racing, you know, that, so we didn't have that kind of a problem.
The problem that I remember is that during the summers we didn't have much to do because the few jobs, you know, racing is not a really, really big town.
And maybe it's probably under 100,000. And the few jobs that teenagers could get all went to white kids.
So I remember there was an A&W Ruth beer not far from where we lived. And I wanted to work there, but of course they, I never got hired. I asked about.
So the only work that I could get was babysitting for, you know, one of my sister's friends. And so that was, you know, in that regard there was not that much difference.
You came back during your senior year. I did.
I thought I would have thought you would have graduated up there and then come back.
You know, I wanted to go to college and my parents thought there may, and I'm not even sure about this, but we thought that there may be a problem without my graduating from a school out of the state and wanting to go to a public school,
because I was originally going to go to Valley State until after I got involved in the movement and, you know, found out about two balloon arms.
So they thought that there may be an issue with my graduating from an, you know, and having an address in Wisconsin and then trying to get into school here.
So I came back and finished up my last semester at Amanda Elzy High School and that's the school that I originally had started the high school across the summer.
Well, while you were gone, we had a lot going on in Mississippi. You had the Freedom Rides, you had the Tougaloo sit-in, and you had the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee,
SNCC coming into McComb and then moving up to the Mississippi Delta.
So by the time you got back, a whole lot was going on in and around Greenwood, with voter registration campaigns, white violence, police dogs being set loose on demonstrators, the federal government sort of coming in, but not really doing much.
Tell us what it was like coming back into that and what motivated you to jump in with both feet.
Well, when I was in racing, I got involved with I joined the Youth Group Youth Chapter, the NAACP there, and we heard about what was going on down here, you know, with Meredith and the Freedom Rides and all of them.
We actually thought that we could get a bus and come down here as a bunch of about 20 students who were in, 20 of us who had been involved in the NAACP, but that just didn't happen.
So when I came back here in the winter in January of 1963, I mean things were going full blast because we hadn't been back here in a couple of years, so I didn't know what to expect.
But I mean the movement was in full force in Greenwood and in it, and then a friend of mine invited me to attend the mass meeting in Greenwood, and this must have been maybe around a couple of months before I got out of high school.
And when I got to that mass meeting, I tell you that it was just amazing what all the Freedom Songs and all these young people who were leading things.
I mean, I think Hollis Watkins was there, Lawrence Guyot was there, John O'Neal, Mary Lane, and then I met my lifelong friend, June Johnson, and I became very close to June and her family.
But that night at that meeting, I knew that I had just found exactly what I was looking for, and that was the opportunity to work with people to change the conditions that we lived in.
All my life, I knew that I was not going to be living the kind of life that my parents lived.
And what did your parents think about your getting involved in it?
They were a little bit reluctant, you know, to let me get involved in it.
I'm going to tell you a story about what my father, he had a conversation with Longsky out.
When I told after I graduated high school, I told him I wanted to get involved full time in the movement until the fall when I could start college.
So my father was really reluctant, he said, I'll tell you what, I'm going to go ahead and let you get involved, but you've got to give me the name of somebody who's in charge over there.
And I said, well, that's going to be kind of hard, because I don't know who's in charge.
It looks like there's no one particular person.
And I think my father said, well, I heard about this fellow named Lawrence Guyot.
And so he said, I'm going to call him, you give me his number.
My father found the number somehow.
And I didn't want him calling, telling somebody to be in charge of me and all that.
But anyway, when you were two later, I was in the SNCC office in Greenwood.
And Lawrence Guyot came up to me and he said, I got a call from your daddy.
I said, oh, don't tell me.
He said, and he put me in charge of you.
He told me that if anything happened to you, that I'm going to be, he's going to hold me responsible.
And he, I never let me forget that, never.
And you met Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer about that time.
I met Mrs. Hamer.
Relationship, your early relationship, impressions, friendship.
Okay.
I really got to know Mrs. Hamer.
I'd seen her around the office.
I'd seen her to sing in mass meetings.
But I really had not actually gotten really close to her until Annelle Ponder,
who was at that point with SCLC.
And she wanted a group of people to attend citizenship school in South Carolina.
And I was one of the ones who was selected.
Ms. Hamer and June Johnson and several other people were selected to go to the citizenship school.
Was a two week school.
And when we got to the bus station, so we were going to ride the bus over there.
Annelle Ponder set to us.
Can we stop on that?
Yeah, sure.
Okay.
So when we were getting ready to leave,
and we left out of Greenwood to go to Charleston, South Carolina,
Annelle Ponder set to us, you know, I will be using the white side of the waiting room whenever we stop.
And because it's illegal for them to still have two separate waiting rooms and bus stations.
And she said, you don't have to do this because we're unlikely to get arrested for doing this,
especially when we're in Mississippi.
And I'm not saying that you have to do it.
I'm just telling you that if you want to, it's your choice, but I will be doing it.
And so on the way over there, whenever the bus stopped, we used the waiting room on the white side without any problems.
And we were over there for two weeks.
And Myles Horton was one of the people, you know, Myles Horton from the Highlander.
And Septima Clark was one of our teachers, and there was a man who was an Esau Jenkins,
and it was one of the instructors.
And that's Guy and Candie Carawan, Caroline during that time.
And we learned, just learned all the basics about what it meant to be a citizen.
What's your rights were, how important it was to vote.
And that was just demonstrating your rights as a citizen of this country.
The right to vote, the right to elect people, to represent you.
And what we were supposed to do from that information that we got from the Citizenship School
was to go back and help and have in conduct workshops to train other people on the importance of what it meant.
And it was your responsibility.
It was our responsibility to be good citizens by getting people to register the vote.
And when you know, and to register ourselves and to actually, you know, to carry out and to do the things that, you know,
once you became a registered voter, and to carry out your civic responsibility as a citizen.
And with the SNCC project and voter registration, while you could just move right back into that with what you'd learned.
So by the time, see, at first, you know, SNCC was, was focused, I learned this later on direct action.
But by the time I got involved in the movement, the focus was on voter registration.
So that's what I got involved in, voter registration, a lot of canvassing, you know, the door to door in Greenwood.
June and I were always together walking the streets, she knew the area.
And we walked the streets of Greenwood, you know, and we also went to, in my hometown, went to Itta Bena, Mississippi.
And, you know, people really didn't want to listen to me, especially the folks in my hometown, didn't want to listen to me about anything.
And they said, you know, we've been doing just fine, you know, the way we were, I think that they were really just afraid.
You know, it's not that they didn't want to my own parents, didn't register until, well, I was involved in movement.
And my involvement got, my activities got them involved.
And they, neither one of them had registered to vote on, you know, prior to my involvement in the movement.
They registered and they both, my father, who was a good bit older than my mother, was in his 60s.
I think in his 60s, the first time he voted.
And my mother was in her late 50s early 60s, the first time they voted.
And I will tell you from that time on until they die, they never missed the opportunity to vote.
Okay, tell us about the bus trip back from South Carolina, one of the most infamous journeys in the movement history.
Okay, we left. I can't remember what day of the week it was, but it was probably a weekend, like maybe a Friday.
So we all boarded the bus and we just made the assumption that we were going to repeat our activities of using the so-called white side of the waiting rooms every time we stopped.
And we did that several times.
And our last stop must have been in, I guess, an Alabama before we crossed the Mississippi line.
And we got to Winona, Mississippi and we got off the bus several times.
This was pretty near home, wasn't it?
We were pretty near home and we thought, okay, we're almost home now.
So no incidents, nothing happened. We're okay.
And without even thinking about it, several of us got off the bus and we went to use the restroom.
But before we could even get inside, there were car loads of highway patrolmen and local police there.
And they ordered us out and we refused to leave.
And so they just grabbed us and threw all of us in the back seat of one car.
And we just piled us in on top of each other.
And Mrs. Hamer was one of the people who did not get off the bus initially.
When she saw us being arrested, she got off the bus as fast as she could and said, oh, well, I know when they started first arresting us, thrown us in Annelle Ponder, pulled out a pad, and started writing down the license plate number.
And at that point, they just threw everybody in and then Miss Hamer came up, got off the bus and says, what is going on?
What are y'all doing? Why are you arresting them?
And they threw her in to the car too.
And when we got to the jail,
and I guess we went to the city jail of County jail, I'm not sure where we were.
When we got there, the jailer didn't quite know what to do with us.
There was me and Mrs. Hamer and Annelle Ponder and June Johnson.
And I think Rosemary from that I'm not sure the makeup of the group.
But Annelle Ponder was the spokesperson and she got asking questions.
And of course, they called her.
She was an older person, right? And college educators, then very professional.
Very professional, very soft spoken, very articulate.
And she kept asking why have they arrested us?
And she said, you know, what have we done wrong?
And that there was a, you know, we were not violating any laws because the ICC was at the innards.
Commerce commission had already passed this law that it was illegal to have separate waiting rooms.
And we were just exercising our rights as citizens, you know.
And it was very lawful.
But the jailer just kept telling her to shut up.
And then she said something to him.
And now he asked her a question and she said no.
And she, he wanted her to say no sir or yes sir.
And she said, well, I'm not going to say that.
She said, I'll answer your question.
But I'm not going to say yes sir, a no sir.
And at that point, he just, you know, he started hitting her.
And what he did to me.
And then I spoke up and said, because that's what I had no fear.
I don't know.
I mean, what?
You were just a kid.
I was a kid.
And I had never really, you know, had a confrontation with any white person that, you know, I've never seen the kind of meanness and just evilness that, you know, that I witnessed then.
And so, but I still wasn't afraid.
So I said something.
And the jailer took it.
So he had this huge, I don't know if it was his huge ring of keys.
And he took him and he jabbed him in my side and stumped my foot and just told me to shut up.
And I was going to keep on talking and Annelle Ponder just said, that's okay.
Don't say anything else.
And then they put us all in sales.
And so I was, I shared, they had, they had a row of sales.
And so the very first sale was left empty.
And Miss Hamer and I were in the next one.
And then June Johnson and the nail were on down the line.
Annelle Ponder ponder was the first person that they took out.
And since Miss Hamer and I were in the sale right next to the empty one, what they did was that they took us into,
they would take you into a sale, that empty sale.
And make you lie on a cot and there were two trustees who were there.
And they were, you could smell the alcohol on them.
They really didn't want to do what they were doing.
But they made them drink and then they were, they told them to be it.
So you had to lie on this cot in that sale.
And I could just hear them, you know, hitting, that this huge strap.
And it seems to me it had holes in it or it had something attached to it.
And they were, I could hear Annelle Ponder just kind of mown and she didn't scream out a lot.
But and then finally they let, they brought her back and they let her pass us.
And I could see that her, you know, her face was bloody.
She was bleeding, her dress was torn.
And then she took June out.
June was a, you know, didn't look, June was only 14, I was sending June was tall girl.
And she looked older, she asked the matter fact, she looked older than I did.
And so they took her out and then the same thing happened with June.
Then they took Miss Hamer out.
And she was in your sale?
She was in my sale.
And oh boy, they really worked her over.
And she just hear her, her screaming and screaming and just, you know, asking them to please stop.
And she said, you know, why are you doing this?
She said, you, you are just like me, you know, you're, you're black like me.
So why are you, why are you beating me?
And they just, they kept going at it and finally they brought her back.
And then they took me out and took me to that sale.
And they made me lie on this cot.
And they raised a strap up and just hit me one time.
And at that point, the jailer came in and said, stop.
Take her back to her sale.
So we're thinking at what happened by that time, is that?
Because two people, one or two people had been left on the bus.
And they had gone back to Greenwood and they told everybody what was going on.
And so they immediately started calling and looking, trying to find us.
And I think what happened by that time, Lawrence Guyot also had probably made it to wine on it.
But they arrested him. We never saw him.
They arrested Lawrence Guyot really beating him up, really, really badly.
And, you know, I didn't think about this until later.
I said, I wonder if one of the reasons that Lawrence Guyot was so adamant.
I mean, he was that kind of a person anyway.
He had promised my father that nothing would happen to me.
And so he said, oh my God, I've got to get that girl all the time.
You mean worse than face than your father than the sheriff?
No, no.
So Lawrence Guyot was beaten and so they brought me back to the sale in his hammer.
By this time, I'm thinking it must have been Sunday.
It was Sunday night.
And Miss Hamel was in such pain.
Her hands were all black and blue and swollen.
And her buttocks were all swollen and hard.
And she developed a fever.
And the only thing I had was a washcloth.
And we had a sink there which, you know, I put, kept putting cold water on it.
And, you know, and putting it on her forehead trying to bring a fever down.
And we, we didn't get any sleep, of course, that night.
And so what we did do, I mean, we decided, you know, when she calmed down a bit and the pain wasn't so bad,
we decided that we would sing some, some songs.
And Miss Hamel.
I had no idea what that's news to me.
Yes, we did.
We decided to sing a bit.
And we did, just, you know, a few songs we didn't sing all night,
but we did it quietly, you know, for ourselves.
And one of Miss Hamel's, of course, her signature song is this little light of mine.
We didn't, but she wanted to do the gospel songs.
And one of her favorite songs, her gospel songs is, if I can remember the name of it, walk with me.
And we did that one.
And it was just powerful and it calmed her down.
And it was like, you know, walk with me, Lord, please, this is going to make me cry.
It's okay.
So, I'll stop.
Okay.
It's...
Can we stop on that?
Snick knew that you were there.
They had people calling the jail, lawyers calling the jail.
And did that have an impact on how you were treated from that time on?
Well, I think it did, because there were no more beatings.
And we did.
We were roused one night.
And we didn't know.
They talked about moving us, because I think that they thought that people knew where we were.
And they weren't quite ready to let us go.
So, they talked about moving us in the middle of the night.
And we decided, and now decided, that we were not going to go anywhere.
We were really going to just, because we didn't want to be taken out somewhere in the middle of the night, and, you know, and disappear forever.
So, Annelle Ponder was really very outspoken at that point, and told them that, you know, that we're not going anywhere.
And we're not going to take us anywhere.
And so, they decided not to do that.
And they put us back in ourselves.
And I'm just...
I'm telling you, I don't remember much of what happened after...
We were arrested, I think, maybe on a Sunday.
We stay there, maybe until Wednesday.
Or so, and I don't have a lot of recollection of the day-to-day activities of what happened.
And then, I think there was on Wednesday, Andrew Young, and there was someone else who came with him to get us out of jail.
He informed us that the first thing he told us, he said, I've got some sad news.
And I'm pretty sure this is right, this is accurate.
He told us that Medgar Evers had been killed, and assassinated the night before.
And he said he had left a meeting in Jackson, and he was on his way home, and he'd been ambushed and killed.
And so, you know, the joy of getting out was just totally overshadowed.
I really didn't know Matt here. I knew who he was.
But it was just a sad, sad day.
Well, for a lot of people, that would have been an indication it's time to get out.
I paid my dues, let somebody else...what was your attitude after that?
My attitude was that I was just getting started.
You know, I'm 17 years old, and I'm home, and this made me more determined to stay involved.
And that was Miss Hamas attitude, too.
I mean, she said, I'm not going to let this scare me off.
And so, that's when I think that time and the one on the jail for all of us,
especially for Miss Hamas, it was like a watershed event.
It was a turning point for her.
And after that, it's when she really came into her own, and she became a national, you know, just a national figure.
And that great voice of hers singing and speaking everywhere.
And she told the story of Winona, Mississippi at the Democratic National Convention,
a year later, with an audience of millions.
And it was the dramatic point of the entire convention.
There was a trial held in Oxford, and you attended?
I did.
There were people who were charged, talk a little bit about that.
That's sort of a footnote, but interesting, I think.
You know, during that trial, they got our story, okay?
We were in Oxford for maybe, for several days, or probably about a week.
And when I took the witness stand, because we were not allowed to hear anybody else's testimony,
when I took the witness stand, I was simply asked just a couple of questions.
I mean, was I arrested?
I said, yes, was I beaten while I was in jail?
And so, my answer was no, because I got one litre with a strap.
And they gave me no opportunity to explain about what I heard, what I saw.
They only wanted to know what happened to me.
So, I don't really know much about what went on.
We were, like I said, we were not allowed to hear anybody else's testimony.
And you were just kept away, and I spent maybe less than five minutes on the witness stand.
Well, it seemed like the prosecutor, if you can say that,
would have been more interested in getting your story out.
No, that was not the case.
I was not allowed to elaborate on anything.
And I think they seized on the, what I said, no, I was not, I mean, I don't call,
look, when I heard what happened to the other people, and the length of time they were beaten,
what I got, I thought was the least of it.
But I'd never had the opportunity to explain that.
Things were starting to happen rapidly in Mississippi then, in the fall of 1964,
COFO, which was the umbrella organization of SNCC and CORE and local NAACP
and other local groups operating under the COFO banner.
I decided to have a freedom vote to dramatize to the country that blacks would vote if given the opportunity.
Tell us about that campaign and your involvement in it.
Well, you know, I think it had been a long held belief that the black people didn't want to have anything to do with politics.
And they would, we wouldn't vote, even if we were given the opportunity to vote.
But that campaign was, I mean, just proved everything that the power structure was saying about what black people wanted and what we would do.
I got involved in it.
And one of the things that I did, though, I mean, from as a result of my citizenship trade, and I had other training too,
I, I know I went to Clarksdale, Mississippi and I went to another place.
And I actually did mock, you know, present workshops, you know, dramatizing what could possibly happen.
At this point, I'm 18 years old and I remember Aaron E. Henry arranged me for me to come to his church and come to his place.
He was the candidate for governor on the ticket.
We held workshops at his church.
And there was another woman who's house I stayed at Miss Piggy.
And it was just, it was just a lot of fun conducting those workshops.
And you know, people just got really, really involved in their roles and all.
And what I know, I mean, the results of it is that there was just a huge turnout and people voted.
And of course, it didn't really, we couldn't really actually vote because people weren't registered.
But they'd show that people had a lot of interest in politics and being able to exercise their right as citizens.
So all this happened.
There was some publicity nationally, not a whole lot.
But a lot of the publicity was devoted to a group of white college students who came down from Yale and Stanford to assist in that campaign.
And although the SNCC had been active in Mississippi for several years now, why the white supremacists were still in control, you now had a revived Ku Klux Klan that was beginning to move.
And the federal government was not very helpful.
So you had discussions in SNCC and COFO about maybe having a summer project where you invite hundreds of people down from the North to work in local communities in part to dramatize the plight of blacks in Mississippi.
But also maybe to force the federal government to take action.
Were you part of those discussions because they became rather heated at times?
Well, I tell you what, I was not, you know, I'm 17 years old and I didn't do a lot of talking.
I was there at the meetings and I basically agreed with what many people were saying because the logic of it was that if the federal government didn't seem to care much about what happened to black people,
we were still being killed and still being the not the right to vote.
But if we brought down the children of affluent people from different parts of the country, and if they received the same kind of treatment that we had been getting, then, you know, the whole country is going to pay attention.
And that is exactly what happened.
You know, when they started being arrested and beaten and killed, I remember that I was a part of the, I did go to Oxford for the summer orientation.
What did you tell us about that? That's a very interesting part.
Well, unfortunately, I mean, my mother took sick, what I was saying.
I left after a day. I had to come back home.
And you were there the first week?
I was there. I left after a couple of the two or three days.
And there were workshops demonstrating to people what could possibly happen to you and demonstrating the non-violent techniques of how to protect yourself, you know, if things happen.
And they were, you know, of course, they were dramatized and they were like, you know, overdone to give people a sense of what could possibly happen and what you have to do in case these things happen.
Because they could actually get to the point where you could be beaten and worse killed.
And before I left, though, we got word that James Chaney and Michael "Mickey" Schwerner and The three Freedom Summer victims, I had not met Andrew because he was one of the summer volunteers going down.
And he left early from the orientation to go back to Meridian with Michael "Mickey" Schwerner and with James.
So I've never met him. I later met his mother.
As a matter of fact, when we were working on the 30th reunion for Freedom Summer, she came down and was a part of that.
So you came back and the summer begins with the news. The three civil war rights workers have disappeared and everybody understood that they were dead.
Tell us about that summer and your role in it, your recollections of what went on.
By this point, okay, in the fall of 1963, instead of going to college, I actually moved to Jackson because I had spent the summer working voter registration in Greenwood and Greenville.
And the spring of 1964, I was in Hattiesburg and McComb, you know, doing voter registration.
With the Freedom Days there?
Yes. And then in the spring of 1964, I was in Jackson and so I started working in the COFO Office.
And the first time the COFO Office was up and running and as you know that it was made up of SNCC and CORE and the NAACP and SCLC.
We all shared a space at this Council of Federated Organizations and we shared this space there.
And we had what we called Long Before Cellphones, the WATS line.
And one of the things that I did was I learned how to use the WATS line and we had to have somebody staff at watch line 24 hours a day, you know, in case somebody called in.
And the WATS line was there so that if somebody got in trouble and you know they needed to get the word out that they were in trouble wherever they were across the state.
And they didn't have access to, you know, they have money to pay for a phone or something to get to a pay phone.
They could maybe use somebody's phone and call in and relay the message.
And they were supposed to check in every day.
They were supposed to check in anyway, every day.
And so that's why we had to have staff there, manning that telephone 24 hours.
And the part of what I did was I took a shift.
I was not out in the field working and during the summer.
But everybody at some point came through the Jackson office.
So I met most of the people who were down that summer.
Who else is working in the office with you?
Well, one of the people was the person that I finally married.
Jesse Moore, he's the father of my five children.
And he had come in from California.
Right, exactly.
So he was one of the people actually, you know, Jesse and Bob and Dave were...
Bob Moses and Dave Dennis.
Bob Moses and Dave Dennis were actually, you know, kind of in short, well they shared responsibilities with one in the summer project.
And I'm trying to remember, oh, who else was in that office?
I met Gwen Gillon that summer.
She worked because she was a student.
She's from Alabama.
And she was a student, yeah.
And I met her.
Well, I actually met Gwen, I guess, in maybe India, maybe the spring of 1964.
And we became really, really good friends.
I'm trying to remember who else.
There were several people who were...
I'm trying to remember if Mary King was there, Casey Hayden.
And these were young white women from the South who had been active and snick for a while.
Right, right.
Dona Richards Moses Moses, who at one point was a Dona Richards Moses Moses.
She and Bob were married.
And I'm trying... I don't remember who else was working in that office across the summer though.
Did you ever come across Worth Long?
Oh, yes, yes.
You heard any stories about Worth Long his friend's life?
Oh, Worth Long his friend's of yours.
Well, Worth Long used to come to town.
And he stayed at a house many a nights, you know, whenever he would come through and need a place to stay.
And Worth Long was really involved in... he was an oral historian.
He liked to go out in the countryside and just talk to regular people and find out what was going on.
And I remember later he was instrumental in getting the Blues Festival up in the Delta Blues Festival.
And he did a lot of... arranged a lot of the documentation for the Blues Festival.
So he was kind of a folklorist and he... that's what I remember about Worth Long.
And I saw him recently at... and I was just surprised to see him because I knew Worth Long it had been sick.
But I saw him at the Cofo office.
There was something going on just a few months ago I believe.
And so it was really good to see him.
I thought him and said he's been feeling better the last year.
So it was really good to see him up and about.
Anything stand out in the summer?
Incidents? Things you were involved in? Violence?
Well, there was always... there's, you know, violence all over the state being reported.
And I'm just... I'm trying to remember this has been 50 years ago, John.
And it's... I'm trying to remember details if you want to ask me about...
There was something... well, there was something that I came across about...
You're going to a movie as a Lamar theater or... or downtown and...
Oh, really?
Yeah, now I...
What did I go to see?
Oh, it was... it was something and a young man was...
I think this West Side story was something.
Oh, yes, yeah.
Oh, my... I don't remember the details that...
Somebody... one of your friends at the meeting was...
At the movie was taken out and beaten and put in jail.
I'm sorry. I just...
Well, maybe... maybe somebody has made that up.
I don't know. It couldn't happen.
But I do remember going to the movie.
And at that time, you know, integration was just...
Yeah, you know, beginning to take hold and...
But still kind of... you know...
Well, in Greenwood, of course, they had the McGhee brothers, you know,
they were integrating theaters and getting beaten up and all kinds of instances.
One of the major things to come out of the summer project or Freedom Summer was
the challenge of the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party,
which was challenging the legitimacy of the regular segregationist delegation
at the National Convention in Atlantic City.
Talk a little bit about FDP and your relation to it and your thoughts.
Oh, the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
Well, as everybody knows, by now,
if black people couldn't vote, they couldn't participate in the democratic process.
And so the Democratic Party from Mississippi was almost always an all-white delegation.
And this... Freedom Democratic Party was formed and it was made up of a cross-section of individuals,
you know, to kind of reflect the makeup of the state.
And when we went to Atlantic City, I was not actually, you know,
an official part of the delegation, but I went along, I took a bus,
and I think Miss Hayden was on that bus.
Well, we'll talk about your experience there of this.
Okay.
I didn't know that you were there.
Oh, I actually went.
Oh, okay.
So we wrote a bus up to Atlantic City.
And when we got there, of course we couldn't go in.
We spent most of our time, you know, just outside the convention center there.
But I remember that when a few people were allowed in,
then we would share the badges.
And so to allow as many people as possible,
oh, if you could go in at a time.
So the badges were shared.
We had a couple of things to go in for just a few minutes.
And we heard about Miss Hayden's testimony.
And what President Johnson did, you know,
when she was given that really, really powerful testimony.
Called a press conference.
Called a press conference to get her off the air.
But most of our time was just spent, you know, just being there
and being outside, being on the boardwalk,
sometimes singing freedom songs and just giving our support.
Were you talking to people or was that mainly members of the delegation
that we're talking to others?
It was mainly members of the delegation.
What was the mood there that did, was there for a time after Mrs. Hamer's emotional testimony?
Did you think you were going to win?
We thought so.
But, you know, then these factions developed.
You know, of course, there were people who wanted to accept the compromise.
Which was two seats at large.
At large, two seats.
And Miss Haymer and Annie Devine" and maybe Victoria Gray.
And these women, you know, said no.
No, we don't want two seats.
I mean, Miss Haymer said, we don't need two seats.
Two seats.
One of us is tied.
So she was against accepting the compromise.
And there were a couple people who were not a couple.
There were a lot of people who wanted to accept the compromise.
And so, at that point, I think a rift developed between the,
mostly the rural activists who had been down in the trenches really working for, and they
were working for more than just a compromise.
I didn't think it was fair.
I didn't think it was the right thing to do to see an all-white delegation and just
offer the Democrats who had a composition that was more of what the state was made up of.
What was it like on the bus coming back?
Did you, were you depressed?
Did you think you'd made your point?
Were you eager to get back in the field?
Oh, I was eager to get back.
At this point, let's say this is 1964.
And you know, after the summer of 1964, things kind of, you know, we were kind of
what, do we weren't sure about the direction that we were going to go in?
And things just kind of started to, you know, to kind of fall apart in the movement.
We lost the focus, okay.
You know, the voting, I mean, the Civil Rights Act, you know, I think at that point,
you were passed, okay.
And then the following year, though, the Voting Rights Act was passed.
So it's September of 1964.
What are you doing?
I decided to, it was time for me to go ahead and go to college.
And so I enrolled in, and into the college along with several other people, Glenn Gillen,
Hollis Watkins, MacArthur Cotton, and a bunch of other people.
We were in a work state program.
So our tuition was paid, you know.
And so you're focused then shifted more to education after that?
And you're focused on making it shifted to education.
Tell us something about Tougaloo when you were there.
Well let me tell you, I first heard about Tougaloo.
I had no idea what Tougaloo was until, because I was away from here.
So I didn't know anything about the colleges.
I knew about Valley, that's where I'm from, Mississippi Valley State University.
But then one day we had a career day at Amanda Elzy High School, that's a school day.
Now that was a consolidated school that I went to that was right outside of Greenwood.
And we had a representative from several colleges and Tougaloo College was one of the places.
And the man was, he was a foreigner.
He's a black man, but he spoke French.
And he had this wonderful accent.
And he talked about Tougaloo in such glowing terms.
But you know what, I had heard about Tougaloo College, which I forgot.
Because I'm going to tell you this.
When I was growing up, I heard a lot about my great grandfather from my mother.
She said, it's in the family that he actually, that he went to Tougaloo College.
Yes, I've got a picture of my great-grandmother upstairs.
And on the back of it, my mother, it was always fun to write stuff on the back of pictures.
She's got written down, I'll show it to you when we're done.
Professor, she called it Professor Jeff Davis.
Jeff Davis, can you believe it?
Pearson.
And she said he was, he went to Tougaloo College and she lists all his wife, Georgia.
That's the picture of my great-grandmother.
And all of their children, one of his children was my grandmother, his daughter,
birth of Pearson.
And what he did was that he educated, he'd now also have some great-on schools who went to college.
One was in a accountant and one did something else.
That's very unusual.
Very unusual, which I have to remember the times.
This was like that first and second generation.
This was the reconstruction.
When there were possibilities.
Yes, yes.
And so they were educated and they owned land and everything.
And was that generation, my mother's generation, after they lost everything and went back to that system,
well, went into that system, the Jim Crow and the sharecropping and all that.
And my mother just was, when she grew up, she was, you know, she was very sheltered from
the racism and whatever.
And then she married my father, and she got thrown into this world that she knew nothing about.
But anyway, where were we?
I was talking about something else.
Well, we were talking about being at Tougaloo.
Being at Tougaloo.
What it was like in 64, 65.
Well, in 1964, Tougaloo, well, Tougaloo was a really different place from that.
Tougaloo had this history of being this oasis for the movement.
Private school.
Private school, small, private school.
And it had the reputation of really educating people and turning out people who would go on to be
lawyers and doctors and whatever.
And I wanted so badly to go to Tougaloo.
I just didn't think my parents could afford to send them.
But then, after being involved in the movement of someone arranged for scholarships for
those of us who wanted to go.
And so maybe ten of us actually went, started to Tougaloo.
So I went to Tougaloo.
But then I got married the following early in 65.
I got married.
And I started having children.
So I went to Tougaloo for two years, half summer.
What was it like here?
You were all hard in movement veterans and you're at a school with a bunch of kids who,
most of whom have not had.
It was really difficult to settle down and to, you know, to get involved, to try to get
involved in campus life, as a matter of fact, I never really really did.
I just felt so removed from that.
I mean, I went to my classes and I did what I had to do in terms of my studies, but I
didn't get involved much in the campus life.
Except for, you know, I made a few friends.
Okay.
So it was just, it was really hard to make the transition from, have it been involved
in the movement.
I mean, I went to the March on Washington, right?
I'd met Martin Luther King, Stokely Carmichael, and all these people who had been involved
in the movement.
It was just a wonderful, exhilarating, exciting time.
And then to leave that and to come back and to move into a whole other world, the academic
world, when most of the students there, the girls were trying to get into sororities
and the boys, I never did get involved in that.
I just didn't see the point of it.
And so it just happened at a time in my life when I had no interest in doing that.
I'm not saying that it's a bad thing.
It's just that it was just something that I didn't want to do after having been involved
in the movement.
So it was, but it was a good experience.
I made some life-long friends or Tougaloo, like, it, Tougaloo was like a family,
a community in itself, right?
No professors do you remember?
Oh gosh.
I remember, oh my goodness, well, Dr. Naomi Townsend, oh, look, great Dr. Naomi Townsend,
I was in her class, and she had an upper level, I don't know how I got into that English
class, sorry.
And boy, she was strict.
At that point, girls could not wear pants to her class.
I didn't know that.
So I wear pants all the time, right?
I mean, my uniform was jeans for the last couple of years.
And you could wear pants to chapel.
We had to go to chapel, you know, once a week.
I stepped in the Dr. Townsend's class one day and she said, Miss Simpson, I will have
to see you after class.
And everybody started looking me, they knew what was coming, right?
And so she blessed me up and down about you do not come to my class with slack so I
don't know Dr. Townsend.
And then I cut my hair and I was wearing an afro and she said, and another thing, why
do you have to wear your hair like that?
Can't you just, you know, I mean, you're on a college campus now.
Can't you do better than that?
And of course, I ignored her.
That was early on.
There were not many afros.
No, not many afros in 64.
And then on top of that, I used to ride a motorcycle, a tiny little, little white Honda
motorcycle because I lived in Jackson for about a time.
And it's six miles out.
Exactly.
So I tell you there was some notoriety there among the, all the movement people.
I don't know why it was that we were, you know, why we stood out so much because of
the reputation that Tougaloo had of it.
You know, the Tougaloo 9 had been there and it had been very open and we, you know, receptive
to the movement.
I mean, we were accepted and got along well with our classmates.
My experience was, and reading also was that Tougaloo could mobilize its students, get
a whole bunch of people to come into the chapel when there was something going on.
Exactly.
But it was really a much smaller group of students who were active, especially before
1960 for integrating churches and doing things like that.
But remember Dr. Ernst Borinski?
Oh, Dr. Ernst Borinski, of course, Dr. Ernst Borinski.
And then the forums that he held, yes, I used to attend those.
As a matter of fact, when I went to summer school, he taught, he taught me German.
So I only had the one class from Dr. Ernst Borinski.
And but his, I mean, his forums were legendary.
Bringing people who were known internationally who would come to Tougaloo because they'd
heard about it.
Exactly.
He was, you know, he was amazing.
Yeah.
Well, I want you to talk about, well, two things.
First of all, talk about your life in the last 50 years.
And then, well, just tell us about family, about what you were up to, where were you living,
what were you doing?
We won a full record here.
Okay.
Well, of course, I was married and then raising five children.
So part of that time, I was just to stay home, and then I kept trying to go back to school.
So I went to Jackson State for a while.
I thought I wanted to be a nurse.
And but this is when my youngest child, Jessica, she just had a birthday.
She's 35 now.
Is she the attorney?
She's the attorney.
I met Jessica.
Jessica, okay.
Okay.
So when she was maybe two, a couple of years old, I went back to school.
And I took all kinds of, you know, the sciences, the biology, and chemistry, and all that
stuff.
And after about a year of that, I said, oh, I don't think I want to do this.
So I stopped out again.
And then I went, I, in 1986, I believe, I started, to 86, 87, I started the Millsaps College.
And I went for a semester.
What was Millsaps College?
This is a predominantly white school, a good liberal arts college in Jackson.
Well I tell you, Millsaps College was, I tell you the most difficult school that I had ever
been to.
But I did better at Millsaps College than I did anywhere.
I was practically a straight-ass student, you know.
I was going part-time.
But the last year that I was there, I was a full-time student and working full-time and
raising children.
And I did really, really well.
I had some really good professors, Mr. Bavender.
Oh, did you know him?
Oh my gosh, he was just the most amazing man.
And he liked me.
So he took extra time with me.
I was, you know, at this point I'm in my 40s, right?
You know.
So I really liked Mr. Bavender.
And I had other teachers too, that I liked Millsaps College.
When Millsaps College was, it was really, really, it was very challenging for me.
But I enjoyed my time at Millsaps College.
And I finally graduated from it.
I stopped and then I went back and so that last time I was there, I was going full-time.
That's one of the old students there.
Oh, I was.
And I was right in there with these young kids and I was holding my own.
And the students who were younger would say, you know, well, you don't have anything to
do.
You just, you know, you're just here taking a class or two.
And I had a correct them.
I know I'm full-time.
I'm working full-time.
I'm raising children.
So don't ever tell me I don't have anything to do but study.
You know.
Where were you working?
I was working for a time.
I worked.
Okay.
When I started out, the very first job I had was I was a legal secretary for the Lawyers
Committee for Civil Rights Under Law.
I had gone.
I'd been in, I got my training for that when I don't know if you've ever heard of MDTA.
I mean, the manpower training in New York, yeah.
Yeah.
Great society program.
Yes, exactly.
So Hinds Community College had got funded for one of those programs and they had a stenography
class that they school.
And we went to that class for a whole year, five days a week, eight hours a day to prepare
us.
And so the first job that I got was as a legal secretary when I got out of that for the
Lawyers Committee.
And after that, I went to work for Head Start.
In Jackson?
In Jackson.
Well, Friends of Children of Mississippi is the one I got involved in.
It was after the CDGM business, you know, Friends of Children of Mississippi was formed.
And I went to end the director of that was an old slick person, Fred Mangrameth Thomas.
Oh, yes.
You remember your friend?
Yeah, I got a friend.
Okay, at the time that I was involved there.
And then later I was an administrator, well, an office manager at Voice of Calvary's
health clinic because I moved to Jesse and I moved our kids to the country.
We lived in Simpson County, Mississippi for about four years.
And so I worked at a health clinic in Mendenhall, kind of running that health clinic for a
while until I moved back to Jackson.
And then after that, I, you know, I went to college and then I also worked at Delta State
University for a while.
This is about, and I think the late nights in Cleveland in the Delta, I was a program administrator.
Then we had three AmeriCorps programs.
And so I was one of the people who was, who was running those three programs.
But also during that time, I met Les and, you know, I got a divorce and so I met Les and
then we were together.
We got married.
We've been married for 15 years.
But prior to that, you know, a few of year to before that, I was working with him in
his business, he had a consulting business that managed federal and state contracts.
We also did work with the Kellogg Foundation.
And one of the things that we did, we worked, we were community coaches.
What's your community coach?
A community coach is set as a person who works with, okay, the Kellogg Foundation had
an initiative called the Mid-South Delta Initiative.
And what they did, they worked in the three states, Mississippi, Louisiana, and Arkansas.
And they funded programs and projects and communities, but these communities had to have
involvement across the boundaries.
You had to, you know, be inclusive, inclusive of, you know, not just black people, but it
had to be made up of, you know, citizens across the boundaries in those communities.
And what they did was that they came up with, they found problems in their communities
that they wanted to try to correct.
And they would write a proposal and get it funded and they could have like maybe $100,000
or something to get some of those initiatives worked on.
And the community, the coach would coach them and, you know, to how to set up their
organizations, how to bring the different factions together, just help them through the process
of fulfilling the obligations of the grant, if they got.
And one of the really exciting things that we did during that time, we wrote a side proposal
to get, to take several trips to Africa.
We took some of the participants in these organizations to, we took three trips.
As a matter of fact, we went to Ghana for a two-week period and we took a mixed group, the
young people and old people and then we went to Ghana and Ghana once.
And on that particular trip, Mrs. Lillierre's, who was at that point, 75 years old and she
had always wanted to go to Africa, she was on that trip with us and she was a truth,
but she was absolutely amazing.
Mrs. Ayers is the widow of Jake Ayers, who is an activist and he was instrumental
in that Ayers v. Fordice that's still being played out right now.
And then the last one other trip that we took, a group of just 30-somethings and under,
what and the whole thing that we wanted to do, we hooked up with a group called Travel
and Learn and we planned on a tenorery that would, you know, just, it was, some of the
people had never even been on an airplane and they went, you know, for the Mississippi
Delta to Africa.
And they interacted with, you know, they got introduced to international travel, got introduced
to, you know, to be living in other cultures and sometimes roughing it and sometimes, you
know, living better than they had been living at home, you know, because we stayed in really
great, great hotels.
It must have been fun.
It was amazing.
It was really, really fun.
So then I also did social work.
The last thing I did was that I worked with, what's he wanted, the, let's see, I can't
think of the name of it now, the development groups, the young community development groups
and they had a program and aging program and so I did social work for about three years,
living with people who had been victims of the Katrina, storm and these were older people
who had been displaced and then moved to the Jackson and surrounding areas and we were
helping them navigate the system just trying to get resources for them whether it was health
care or, you know, ride to the doctor, food, just whatever they needed and so I did that
and that was very, very rewarding.
I'm still, you know, I still keep in touch with one or two of the people that I worked
with, one of my, the cases that I managed.
You have been living in Mississippi most of your life.
You participated in the most important social movement the country has seen since the crusade
to freed the slaves and you've seen a lot of change take place and the final question
is for you to just to tell us what you think the major positive changes that have taken
place in the state as a result of the movement and what needs to be done, what are the major
problems facing us today?
Well, all right, well of course some of the positive things on is that, you know, that
there's a lot of surface changes, okay?
Well, I mean, there are a lot of changes that you can't really quantify either or, but some
of the major changes is that, okay, during the movement, what one of the major things that
happened is that black people, you know, got a sense of who they were, better sense of who
they were and that they started to re-value weight and to rethink about who they were
and their Worth Long and begin to just to see themselves in a different kind of way, to see that they
were not powerless and we always have power, but they had somehow given up our power to other
people.
But in order to get it back, you know, when change is coming, it's sometimes like Bernie's
Reagan thing, she starts out on one of the songs that they, on one of her albums, says
when you see changes coming, if you want change, you have to walk into the storm and when
you get to the other side, things will be different.
And so that's, you know, kind of how I see the movement.
People actually just, you know, not knowing what was going to happen to them, they actually
walked into the storm because they needed and wanted change and things have been different.
So now I live in this neighborhood when, you know, 50 years ago, I couldn't have lived here,
you know, it's predominantly white, the houses are nice in this neighborhood.
I can live, people can live in where they want to live, the schools, now that's a different
story.
The schools in Jackson, you know, there was white flight from the schools, most of the white
people go to, still go to, I mean, at this point, they're in private schools, the academies
are still, you know, very much alive.
The public schools are probably 90 percent black.
So in that regard, we're about where we used to be and people always point to the changes
being, you know, the number of black elected officials that we have, but that's, you know,
that's, that's a change, but I don't know how that has, you know, played out for the
average person, how that has really benefited the masses, you know.
So what are the major problems then facing?
The major problems are still, I mean, you know, crime, I'm just looking at our area here.
There's lots of crime, there's the school system is in Jackson and some of us around
in areas, not very good.
And so, you know, we're trying to work on that.
And as it happened, you know, we have a lot of black elected officials, you know, we
have a black mayor, we have the school board is mostly black, we have our city council
is predominantly black.
But what has happened is that, you know, economically, the power structure hasn't really
changed all that much, you know, all the major businesses are still owned by white people.
And a lot of them have moved out of the Jackson area, out of the city of Jackson, and it
to Madison County and Rankin County.
And so what has happened, you know, the tax base has been eroded.
And so if you don't have money to fund the schools, you can't really, you know, improve
it all that much.
And so some of the schools are really in bad shape, you know, every year they do a report
card on the schools and they're just way too many of them that are, you know, C and D
and sometimes F rating.
So we still have a lot of work to do and I think most of it is on education and trying
to control crime.
And they say, you know, there's not as hardy a week that goes by that some, and it's mostly
in this, you know, black on black crime, but some young black man is not shot or, you
know, or killed another one.
And when I was a kid growing up, that kind of stuff was so, so you almost, I remember one
case of a black man killing another one, just one, the whole time that I was growing up
and it was so traumatic that I had nightmares about it.
I only knew what are the men.
I knew the one who got killed.
And it went through our community like wildfire when this man was killed.
And now it's just so ordinary that you just don't, you hardly blink an eye when you
do about it, you know.
Drugs and gangs, imported from the North, they were, they weren't around.
Exactly.
Nobody knew anything about that kind of stuff.
Your children grew up in that time of transition.
This is the final question.
Talk about your kids, what do you do with it?
Okay, let me start with my oldest one.
His name is Earl.
He owns a small construction business.
So he's, you know, he works for himself.
He has a small crew.
Sometimes it's 10 people depending on the jobs that he gets and sometimes it's four or
five, you know.
So he lives in Madison, but you know, his business is in this area.
My next son is Orlando.
He's a fireman.
And so that's the major thing that he does.
Earl is married.
He has four children.
Orlando is also married.
He has three.
And my next son is Omar and he has a couple of kids.
He's not married.
And he is an IT specialist.
And his job was, was bought by another, I mean, his company was sold to another company.
So he lost his job three years ago.
At that point, he decided that he would go back to school.
I mean, he has a degree in political science.
He went to Rust College.
Orlando went to our Alcorn College.
Earl went to two years at high-end community college.
And Omar decided that he would go back and get a degree in engineering and computer engineering.
So he's getting close to finishing that up.
He's in Jackson State.
And then the next one is T, of course, T.
And she has a doctorate and she's teaching at the Ohio State University.
And then my youngest...
Has a book coming out?
As a book coming out, hopefully, within the next year or so.
And my youngest child is Jessica.
And she's an attorney.
She graduated law school at Michigan.
And she's been an attorney now for, I think, seven years or so.
She worked for a local law firm here in Jackson.
And that's it.
You're Mr. Simpson.
Thank you very much for inviting us in.
This has been a wonderful time for me.
And I'm sure that the people at the museum and the many people who are going to be viewing
this will share my sympathy.
Well, John, thank you.
I'm so good to see you.
Yes, it is.
You're in this setting.
This setting, you know.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.